okay now we could do this in a variety
of different ways but just to make it
nice and accessible for us
I want to consider this if I gave you
say this binomial expansion I've just
chosen it because we can do it
relatively easily by hand okay now what
is this equal to
well we actually know this result well
enough and you probably know the row of
Pascal's triangle well enough that you
could just actually help me expand this
out manually right what would the first
term usually bit yeah we usually write
it as a cubed and then the next one
think about the row that we're on what's
the next one gonna be it'll be three
what term am I gonna lump with it a
squared B probably and then we would say
what's the next one it's one three
another three another three right how
many a is how many B's yeah a B squared
and in the very last term will be B
cubes very good okay now what is what
does any of this have to do with this
well if you actually tease this out a
little bit right we've actually
particularly in here we've actually
taken some things here and just sort of
compress them together to write them for
the sake of efficiency right for example
a cubed what it really is is a times a
times a do you agree with that that's
that's what a cubed is short for same
deal with B cubed okay but in here why
have I got three of each one well
there's more than one way to write these
guys right like there's only one way to
write a cubed AAA but you could write
this for example in the order that it's
written you could write it a a B but you
could tell me another way to write that
with the same pronumerals but in a
different order right how would I write
it yeah you could write as a be a
there's another way to do it you could
do baa
right but you see we sort of compressed
these all into one thing because in
multiplication in multiplication order
does not matter do you remember that
right we have a name for this we say
multiplication is commutative you can
just rearrange these guys to be whatever
you want and they're all the same thing
do you agree I mean what about this one
over here how would you write it well
you could write it the way that
written which is a BB but you could
write a different way you could write it
as Bab or you could write it as okay so
you can see what you're doing here right
yeah however you want to read these out
loud right what you aren't doing in in
this thing here is you are doing
permutations and combinations but in the
context of algebra you don't really need
to worry about them being different you
say well I end up with three of them so
you write three and we focus on the
three right but this need one more color
these things here I mean we're gonna
have these ones as well these are the
binomial coefficients because of what
you are doing right you can say this you
could tell the story we've talked about
telling the story in different ways you
can tell the story in a number of ways
to explain why this should give you this
right for example do you notice every
single one of the terms here there's
actually there's eight terms that I've
written in green do you see there are
eight terms but they collapse down into
four when I collect like terms right
those eight terms each time they have
three pronumerals do you notice that
this is gonna be you've got to choose
three right and that should make sense
because this guy here is a plus B times
a plus B times a plus B you've got to
choose three every time right when we
say three to zero it's a little bit like
well you've got three here choose some
of them to be B's right how many of are
we gonna choose them to be B's in this
case well I don't want any B's for this
one okay
for this line here or this set I've got
three spots one two three choose one of
those spots three choose one choose one
of those spots to become a B now you
have anyways can you do that and the
answer is three ways oh can you can you
finish how where I'm going here there
are three spots choose two of them to be
B's there are three spots choose all
three of them to B's there's only one
way that you can do that because they're
all B's okay does this make sense so in
fact we've been doing perms and calms
sort of underneath that's why we sort of
introduced this notation a year ago but
didn't explain what it was about okay
because we had to wait until now so
5p3 business think about this and maybe
you want to write this down as a no fee
because it starts to rapidly become
confusing as you meet questions where
there's not an exercise and it tells you
exactly which one you're supposed to do
5p3 is about permutations that's why
it's a P and that means order matters
okay five C three is with combinations
that's why this topic is called
permutations and combinations when you
combine things their order doesn't
matter if you ever forget if you ever
forget put into your calculator and your
calculator will give you a much larger
number for one of them as compared to
the other so here is five P 3 right 5 P
3 is a huge number because you've got to
consider all of the orders changing your
actual arrangement right but then 5 C 3
will give you a dramatically smaller
number what is it by the way 5 C 3 can
you read 5 C 3 off of you remember these
are all identical when you don't worry
about order these are all identical so
how many rows are there there are 10 5 C
3 is of course 60 divided by 6 which
gives you the 10 it's a small number
because when order doesn't matter a
whole bunch of those options end up
being identical so you don't count them
if that makes sense okay